how do you brand something that is is
challenging for people to understand you
start talking about horses people think
horseback riding people think seabiscuit
don't don't even bring the horses up
but what are we selling
leadership and healing but through
horses right
otherwise you're just like you're just
you're just a speaker i'm the only
person in the world doing what i'm doing
there she is hey hey how's it going
how's it going how are you jen i'm great
i'm great it's hot down here in florida
i'll tell you that much i like it well
i'm in canada and it is it is not so hot
we had a couple of days of hot and now
it's now it's just it's still hoody
weather outside oh my gosh nope i think
i wear a hoodie like maybe twice a year
down here i'm down in west palm so it
doesn't get like that ever
i love it well well uh jamie jen's been
with movement makers for a while and
we're doing a fun ig live together as a
thank you so
what do you got how can i help what's on
your mind well um i just would love to
talk to you a little bit about like you
know how to get the youtube following
going um
last year i had um my account with
facebook was hacked and i got deleted
and facebook was like my main platform
and i had about 40 000 followers and i
was like on the upswing of really doing
some good things and when that got
deleted i fought with facebook back and
forth for like seven months never got my
account back and so um
the good thing is because there's always
like you know something good that comes
from any you know anything um is that it
really encouraged me to branch out into
other platforms and to you know ig and
uh i groaned but i did a tick-tock and
then i had a video go viral and now i
have a decent following there and then
youtube and linkedin and um and i'm a
one-man show so i'm kind of doing
everything myself so um i'm not quite
sure where to begin i'll tell you a
little bit about what i do um i have
kind of a unique business uh and which
if you can help me brand this i will you
know
let's make that our goal that's our goal
yeah exactly exactly so um i do what is
called equine assisted empowerment so i
have six horses
four of which so think um
personality profiling if you've ever
taken like a disc or myers-briggs or
something like that and four of my
horses are one of each of the major
personality profiles so if you believe
it or not horses have personalities just
like we do and we call it the pony
personas you can go to my website take a
quick take and take my quiz and figure
out which worst it is um my bet on you
is that you are a dante
so um each one yes so and we kind of
jokingly what did you start with equine
assistance what was it
empowerment
horses
yeah
empowerment just getting just getting
the words down okay yeah yeah yeah so
it's it's and i actually met you through
uh your life with ray higdon that you
did a while back okay and um ray's had
his team at my place and then they've
done my a lot of my experiences that so
i do basically like corporate team
building empowerment my my um
my primary markets women and my
secondary market is um corporations
business i just recently did a live
um training virtually for a team out in
california that works for facebook
so um so things like that so that that's
really kind of what i do it's it's it's
kind of a challenge to explain it's like
it's like can you imagine the person
that invented gum
you know if you invented gum like how do
you tell people like what it is and how
it didn't have flavor back then it was
just this resin look you eat it no you
don't eat it you just chew it well does
it taste good well no
well does it have good you know is it
that nutrition well no you just what the
hell so that's kind of where i'm at like
how do you brand something that is is
challenging for people to understand so
what are people coming to to the to the
to your center for
so that most of my everything that we do
now is virtual since coded so they're
coming here to understand who they are
like the one of the most powerful
questions you'll ever ask yourself is
who am i and to determine what that
looks like
through a 1200 pound animal is a
completely unique experience
and then um and then to have the
opportunity to come here for you know on
site um as i get more established with
my facility down here cause i just moved
to voice bomb from orlando so
i have uh virtual courses
and i do masterminds okay so when you
say i'm a let's role play with me then
so i get a better sense so i'm a dante
i would bet money on it all right what
what does that mean what what how how am
i enlightened now that i know that i'm a
dante oh my gosh because you're
you know just describe the
characteristics of somebody that you
would meet like you know having a
conversation with them you know you're
decisive you're solutions driven you're
about taking action you're bold um
you're charismatic you know you're
you're either arrogant or affable you're
effusive you're probably a little bit
mischievous
so you know you don't you're not afraid
to get into a little bit of trouble you
know and um you you actually you know
you're out there to change the world
you're out there to do something big
only about 10 of the population are
actually true dante's think uh steve
jobs is dante and and uh tony robbins is
a dante he's like this giant 1200 pound
fiery red
massive presence kind of character and
he's just larger than life and um
and knows and isn't afraid to take
action to do things am i close
well i mean those are great those are
great characteristics i have to live up
to being the dante i guess um
what what time
ray incidentally is a trace who is uh
like like dante is steve wozniak or
steve jobs traces the steve wozniak you
know
and you have you have um trace
characteristics as well and he is uh
this white unicorn type of horse he is
he's white with blue eyes he's
completely unique um
a little bit more introverted a little
bit more of an observer so again you
have these characteristics as well
analytical you're dependable reliable
you uh are trustworthy you're kind of an
old soul you like to get things done you
like to put the period at the end of
sentences
you know something you know things like
that and and you do your best work when
you're creatively inspired so and then
you can even go into like carl young's
the archetypes so like dante's my
warrior trace is my magician uh maverick
who is a racehorse that won more money
than sea basket and got rescued and
ended up at my at my all of my horses or
rescues
do you know seabiscus my favorite movie
of all time what i yes i did not know
that but now i do i've seen that movie
like 30 times oh so now it's a pretty
good movie he's and he's the opposite of
you he's he's your um
your king or queen like he's represents
the sovereign he's calm he's quiet he's
reserved he's he's
regal you know and he takes care of the
whole herd kind of behind the scenes
uh brene brown is a maverick
okay so so these these are your
like dante trace these are your you came
up with these yes okay perfect so these
are my four horses that i that i have
rescued and you know dante trace
maverick and bella i'm a bella
okay so so are people coming to you is
it basically like taking a personality
test but it is exactly like that i
haven't you go take my quiz so you can
go to my website and that's the starting
point like that that's kind of the start
of the funnel
so um i you know i'm do i'm again i'm
doing this on myself if anybody that
loves horses wants to come and um help
me with my social media i need help i'm
drowning and there's so much to do
because people really need this right
now people need to understand like how
to stand in their truth how to have this
journey for themselves and we take them
down this this incredible experience
through horses to understand that
and um with the ultimate mission to say
can save horses and change lives
okay so then what's the connection that
by
a certain percentage of your profits go
to supporting more horses or or
yes right well it's
i think of d you've ever had an
impossible burger
you ever ever heard yeah the vegetarian
one yeah yeah right so the and beyond
meat and impossible burger were both
invented by to the same gentleman named
pat brown so pat brown number one that
the impossible burger actually wanted to
subvert climate change by encouraging
people that were on the fence between
eating meat or eating
a vegetarian option at least something
that didn't taste like you know
that tasted good he knew he wasn't going
to get the backyard kansas city barbecue
or to get to go vegan but he could maybe
have an option to so that was that was
his thing but his whole goal wasn't to
make a veggie a veggie burger his whole
goal was to subvert climate change
so
how do you do that you can't you know
again you're not just going to get
people to stop eating meat you got to
give them a quality option so he took a
subversive approach to a socially
conscious problem and that's exactly the
same thing i'm doing because again what
do you think of when you think of a
horse you think of you know their speed
you think of the ticky derby seabiscuit
you know um the budweiser clydesdale you
think of their that their physical
capability but what we're doing is we're
healing people
we are i'm do i'm working with
post-traumatic stress disorder victims
i'm working with veterans i'm working
with women from abuse but it doesn't
have to be like that
and it can be like i said you know right
you know people bring their teams here
for
um you know touted why does susie in
accounting hate doug and marketing well
if we understand that susie's a maverick
and you know it's just team building
right team building with horses
understanding yourself through horses
all with the mission of showing the
world because only one out of 11 people
own a horse
showing the world the power that horses
can have outside of their physical
ability outside of their ability to run
fast or jump high
and so when we take that subversive
approach we might get
we might move the needle a little bit on
the tens of thousands of horses that get
shipped out of this country to slaughter
every year for human consumption that's
not okay with me
so human consumption wow okay
yes
why not just go more direct like horses
why not create a a um and i'm just
playing with you here like we're
brainstorming as opposed to going down
the personality test route
why not create a place for people to
heal with horses
i have that
that yes
right now all of my programs are virtual
because i do not have a facility
but um that i can host people on site
and hosting people on site is tricky
because people bring their garbage
will bring their garbage and i don't
want everybody's garbage being dumped on
my horses so anytime that anybody comes
to on-site and having an interaction on
site with my horses that's going to be
like the next level like you need to you
need to have the information you need to
know
some of the things virtually before you
show up
um and then when you can that's like
that's not the first step in the funnel
if that makes any sense yeah but then
it's fine but so there's a process but
yeah it doesn't
but why not make the business healing
with horses
that well that's what it is
kind of but like what what it comes off
as at least in the initial description
is yeah it's a personality test to help
you develop self-awareness through the
lens of my four horses as opposed to no
we're like we're going to help you heal
because i mean horses are mad and i
don't tell you how magical horses are
but
if the business is not about like it
feels almost like a gimmick
that okay here's the person and another
that's not meant to offend you you're
not going to if it's if it's like if the
real thing is i want to heal people
through my horses or through horses in
general and
and that leads to saving more horses
around the world as well
and that leads to like you have your
center now four but maybe that becomes a
hundred horses and maybe you open up
centers in i don't know i don't know
what states allow you know i wanted
my vision is huge so yeah and and all
you need is four you don't need 400 but
four can feed 400 you know just by
having a program with four trained
horses to to offer this you know
and branding my for but i i get i hear
your point
so
it's like a it's like a retreat you can
have you can have a retreat experience
yep right that's how i started until
coveted i was doing i was i was only
live i didn't have any virtual any
virtual programs at all okay but things
are opening up things are back yes
uh and and florida's florida's been open
for
ever it never closed
so you're good i'm in canada we've the
the most restrictive
you know laws and stuff but yeah i know
right now right now i don't have an
on-site facility
that i can host people go
um partner with somebody who does
i did that last summer i i'd
how do what i really want to do because
i don't have the reach
that i would have
with a virtual program i really want to
get my the virtual programs so i can
have more reach
and people can then use my virtual
programs and have their horses in canada
and i don't have to be there if they
come and experience my my virtual
programs then they can go to a facility
in canada and experience it there with
any horses that are trained with my
methods
so you have a couple options i mean
at the at the i think at the end of the
day
what we need to get across is people are
healing through the horses correct
it's not about the personality test to
know that you're extrovert introvert
dante whatever it's like you you can
heal
your wounds your trauma and become more
whole by
following this process
to being with horses so then it becomes
is there any
micro healing that can be done
through
through through an instagram live
through a zoom through a virtual like
hand that can if i can't actually touch
the horse but dante is coming up and you
know snorts into the camera or something
like can i still
that's
micro heal right so
instead of thinking like just about
reach i i get it but it's more about
like can we give can we help people can
we heal people the business is healing
people right initially when you said i'm
thinking of branding my horses and
you're going or branding the business
you're going through um
uh personality i was thinking like
horsepower like you should horsepower
just makes a lot of sense but but
healing with horses
that's the brand
yeah dealing with horses is the brand
yes
healing with horses so everything that
we do now is about how do we heal people
with our horses
okay and
i don't know what an online experience
looks like and and that's like how do
you how can you create something that is
authentic that like yes people are
getting an experience and you feel
um
is true
you know like it's not just
it's not just a pony show
right we're not just like bringing some
horses out and say hey you're here like
it actually how can we create an online
experience that will be actually healing
for people not as much as actually being
able to touch dante or ry dante or hang
out with dante but still there's
something in there um
i don't know what that program looks
like but it but that's that's the
program where you're taking people's
trauma and issues and where they've been
burned and we're helping them heal
yes that the programs are created okay
that's done like i have um a one hour
free thing i do every week
i have um i go live pretty much every
day with some kind of something
um and i have like you know a five-day
challenge that i do once a month that's
like i go
for the first four days i go through
each one of the horses and help you
understand you know why bella is
codependent why maverick needs trust why
you know trace needs motivation and you
know why dante needs engagement
and like what each personality needs to
go through the healing process and then
on the last day um i i give some
addition you know i give some bonus
materials and then i go through my stack
is the healing more dependent on the
personality type or the type of trauma
that they've been through
the personality types believe it or not
that the type of trauma's trauma man
doesn't really matter what kind it is
i really want to be clear too because
this isn't just about trauma this is um
because you know there's two types of
people that go to for any kind of
personal development experience
um it's the people that want to heal and
that have a gap in their life they want
to close and the people that want to go
to the next level
so you know you have those those two
types and um i i want to i do want to
cater to both
but i don't only want to cater to the
people that are suffering from trauma
because i mean it we all need healing
because healing is not just healing a
wound healing is transcending where we
are in my opinion yeah
so that's really what it's about and and
understanding
um who you are will help you understand
how to heal because you don't it's it's
totally dependent on the personalities
you
dante's going to heal by
going out and you know
chopping down trees or going to
kickboxing or something where maverick's
going to heal by reading a book or
meditating right and there's just
different everybody has their different
ways of of processing stuff and
understanding who you are will
understand how you need to heal and
that's what i teach
how do we how do we turn it into a
healing experience
beyond just the
like dante represents something
he represents a personality type but
like if dante wasn't a horse and and you
just had your four personality types yep
and you go tell them okay go chop down
trees or go
hit your next mission or go you know
whatever it is how do you
how do you actually
start the healing process with the horse
live together
instead of telling me to go read the
book or something i take um i
i tell stories
i take them through a metaphor i'll take
them through like i i'll have um i'll
have like a two a couple of cones and
i'll do like a figure eight with the
horse
and and i'll have him and then like a
jump and i'll have him jump and jump so
i'll have him do two very and all four
horses i'll have him do like the same
task
but i show people how they show up
differently
everybody's doing the exact same task
but they're all doing it differently and
as their me as their leader or as their
healing facilitator i'm there to
shout like you should see this i mean
it's incredible it really is it's it's
so hard to explain because so bella will
be out there and she's like zooming
around the figure eights and she has to
like she feels like she needs to over
achieve all the time and she's a pleaser
and she's codependent she second guesses
herself
and so being able to be empowered and to
slow down
and get focused and understand that
simple things done well
is actually how it's going to bring you
more centered so i take them through the
process and they watch bella they watch
your ear change they watch your body
language change they watch her breathing
change
and go from whatever she's doing where
she's a little bit concerned to oh
it's just a figure eight
and then i'll get trace out or dante out
trace for instance because he's the
opposite of her i take him through the
figure eight and i'll say trace just
trotting
slow like the chain gang just watching
him go oh we're doing this again
and then showing what i can do as his
leader as his mentor as his facilitator
to get him to be inspired about doing
the exact same task he thought was
boring 30 seconds ago and how that can
get him more centered
and then i can take dante and say okay
stop trying to turn the figure eight
into something else and make your own
game out of it because if you aren't
ready for a dante
dante's are always ready for you
they're always ready they always have an
answer and you got to be one step ahead
of the dantes
and then the same thing with mavericks
same exact exercise doing the demos with
mavericks are really hard because all
maverick mavericks need time
and patience and need to learn how to
build trust and so i'll do the exact
same exercise with each horse and show
very different uh tactics and very
different ways to allow them to become
their true centered self in like a 30
minute demo
so then how can we take the demo
to an experience
and like the easiest one to be like hey
there they're on the horse but that
doesn't scale because you're gonna do
four at a time and there's views man but
so what could we do
so that it's an experience for people so
they're not just watching it happen and
you're talking about it because somebody
a horse walks out they don't know what
horses is but if they've gone through it
like oh that's dante i'm a dante and
they can see it happen okay
i can see it but how do i feel it
maybe it's
like are we doing a group
meditation session and we're all
touching dante or are we like what can
we actually do together do we go for do
all the dantes go for a 7 a.m hike
together and we're walking we'd take
turns like holding dante or that's
that's the easy part when you're talking
on site like when you if you come to
come down i'll do if you're ever next
time you're in west palm beach come and
experience it my gift
my gift to you because you'll it's magic
you that is not the hard part the
tripping block that i need to help with
is um
how to make it a virtual experience you
know because people are like people will
be on and like when i presented i
presented for about 30 people and i
would present it for rank makers live a
couple you know a couple years ago etc
like that's the experience and what i
what i had to do when covet hit was i
still had to feed six horses and take
care of 10 acres and you know i still
had all of my overhead so i had to take
off that on-site experience and put it
in a virtual format and i did it
and it's incredible and people are on
from all over the world and people from
dubai and australia and canada and
they're all watching this all at the
same time and i did it live
and it was blowing people's minds
because they were like i never thought i
could have an experience like this with
a horse virtually that would totally
change my life one gal
quit her job the next day and started
her own accounting firm you know i mean
the results are mind and then started
doing this feminine movement dance thing
totally changed your life change your
relationship with her husband changed
her business changed everything from
this five-day
um this course that i did that now i now
run as a six week mastermind
so um
the marketing i like like see like even
here in this conversation where i keep
coming back i'm like no come on i got
i'm not doing on site right now that's
virtual
that because i really want to be able to
have more impact with more people i
would have never had the impact the
woman that did um from facebook wrote me
after and said that they did their
entire team did a huge trust building
exercise after my course and she's she's
actually flying out to visit me after
doing my course for an hour
you know and it was it was virtual and
so once people dip their toe into this
pool they don't they could care less if
it's horses or dogs or squirrels they're
like this is impactful because what you
see isn't a color or an um an infj or
you know a thing it's an animal like to
your point how did you feel what did
what do you experience on the 31st time
you watched sea biscuit you've seen it a
million times but that movie makes you
feel a certain way so does this and it
allows you to create
in your mind a visual and experiential
um idea of who like how to deal with the
dantes of the world that are kind of
pushing your num you know pushing your
buttons the traces of the world that you
can't get off the couch how to
understand who you are
so how do i get that message out to
people in a way where they want to you
know they want to convert they want to
you know that why would i get
conversions
does that make sense yeah i don't want
to do the on-site at the moment not
right now
but so you've got options like in terms
of the branding i would call it heal
heal with horses or healing with horses
it's different it's unique it stands out
especially if you're going after a
business world you're going to rank
masters or other conferences like we're
going to do what with horses like it's
different yes uh the personality stuff i
would not lead with
okay
it might be how you get there
right like once they're in they don't
know how they're going to heal with
horses then then we're following jen's
methodology right and and part one of
the and like hey okay we can't overwhelm
the horses so we're gonna do x you have
to know your dante before you go in and
hang with dante or whatever whatever
your four steps or eight steps or ten
steps or your steps yes but but people
don't care about the steps no they they
want the the healing with the horses
that's what we've been promised how do
we heal with horses okay
anybody who you've done anything with
you try to turn it into an annual thing
so
um if you don't if you did rank masters
and you'll have to cool how do i speak
at the next event how do i speak like
you speak at every ranked masters going
forward
if you've done something with facebook
cool how do we turn this into an annual
thing got it so that every year or every
quarter we come in and we help like
facebook is such a big company that they
could if they loved you they can enter
you to other departments but you have to
ask for it right they have a great time
like hey is there anybody in
another department oh yeah
that might be a good figure
like three days ago so and she was blown
away
blown away
so so while she's still feeling
the energy
before she moves on to
all the other things that are she's
dealing with in her life right yes
i messaged her right before i got on
here so i'm on it
that's
yeah i'm on it man so okay so with her
team it's like with her with her who's
making who's the decision maker for her
group how can you come in every quarter
or every year and do it again because
there's new people who come in all the
time there's new team members who come
in all the time there's new issues that
pop up all the time and even if they had
you in six months ago it doesn't mean oh
now they got it and they don't need any
reinforcement or training ever again
right
so so everybody that you've done
something with
now we create an annual program with
them so it's not a one and done thing
it's an ongoing thing
one to many i think is really where i'm
gonna have more impact too
well not necessarily
you know like i think the ability to
hang with the horses
actually be there is
magical yes and the way to scale that is
not necessarily you having a thousand
locations across america but you could
train the trainer on how to do it yes
and i have a program like that's already
established all of my programs are
established it's right now just people
don't know what it is you know and they
don't know what it they don't know what
it does
well they're going to heal
like the mechanics of how it works
doesn't matter nobody cares
right okay it's like it's the top line
i'm gonna teach you to heal with horses
and we can do it in person or we can do
it as an online event and especially if
you're bringing it to the business
community where
most of the people you know most of the
people in the equine business i'm you
know they're a lot more artists than
they are
entrepreneur yeah oh my god i don't know
so
well but that's the advantage because
but anybody who anybody who raises
horses or is in the equine business
would would talk about how magical and
majestical horses are and how healing
they can be to people and the like
connection they have to people
everybody the vibe that you're putting
out around the horses everybody in the
horse industry would express something
similar they may not agree with like
personality types but most people
wouldn't say like horses are not magical
if you're in the equine business right
but the ability to turn that into a
service that could help
businesses
corporations
nobody knows how to do that
so this is now where you're standing out
and unique and different yes
so we call it healing with horses
everybody has all of their team building
you know there's all that every business
to every major corporation does some
sort of team building where you know
right but not with horses no i'm the
only person in the world doing what i'm
doing and everybody has personality type
stuff that you don't want to be in that
business we're not in that business
we're in the healing with horses
business
how is that going to how is healing with
horses going to translate into
um
like breaking into to corporations
well how do how do you help people like
not what's the result of people
they got they
they got found me through because the
title is leadership with horses
how to be a better leader through
horsemanship this is you were talking my
age-old argument with me and um my
assistant we've gone back and forth
between should it be leadership and like
tony robbins or should it be healing and
more like deepak chopra
because it's both it really is truly
both because you become empowered
through the horses and you heal through
the horses and how you become empowered
is how you heal but you can't you can't
lead with that to you know a corporation
that's having trouble with inner
department conflict you know what i mean
like that's a tough sell
what's the problem with the the conflict
the communication or
you know they're just not doing their
job it's more surface you know you start
talking about healing what for
businesses
you know they they're like
i don't know
individuals that's i think that but i
don't know i could be wrong but my in my
my experience in the past is that from a
business perspective they want
leadership from an individual
perspective they want healing
so you have heal with horses as your
main website
and then if you know you're dealing with
a corporate you can talk about the
leadership benefits of it as simple as
that okay you're you're not you're
you're having we're have we've had this
conversation so many times oh my god
it's
it's like which way do we go the way
you're gonna get most of the business
anyway is gonna like it's service-based
business so the way you get most of the
business is not nobody's searching for
leadership with horses or
like healing events with what like
people are not so we're not winning the
seo game
which is fine to your point about like
we're selling gum people don't know what
it is so
you're gonna get word of mouth
referrals which is why we need to talk
to everybody who's experienced it
create annual programs with them not
just let it be because you could it
could have been great but they may not
be thinking come in again right like you
need to reinforce this we need to do
this every every year every quarter
and and then giving them the tools to
talk about it
absolutely amazing then and that's i
think that's to your point you know
getting getting on people's annual
rosters is brilliant that's that's not
something
i really thought about i thought about
like hitting the businesses and getting
like corporate stuff you know once a
quarter once every six months but i
never thought about doing like summits
and you know i i definitely want to like
one of my goals is to present with you
know grant cardone and you know people
like yourself that know people that know
people because this is it's powerful i
mean i've spoken on stage at tony
robbins i've done a ted talk i'm getting
ready to be published my book's coming
out next month you know so there's a lot
happening um you know for me and i've
been busting my ass for seven years and
actually 18 years with horses so
it's it's been a tough road um i started
out but listen anytime anytime you're
doing a speaking gig or you get a
corporate gig
you default to saying okay we should do
this again in a quarter yeah absolutely
let's create an annual program you have
an amazing experience while they're
still there because then they're going
to go back to their daily life and get
destroyed again so while they're still
in the energy and the vibe they've got
the horsepower with them
uh let's figure out an annual program to
keep this energy going yep because they
need to recharge their batteries and
come back amazing incorporate the other
the other huge win for you is that
people will switch companies and switch
jobs
if you're in touch with not just the
person at facebook but if you stay in
touch with the members who are actually
through it yes and then one of them
leaves somebody's leaving next next
month and they're going to google and
they're going to they're they're going
to tick-tock and they're going to other
companies that's brilliant if you're in
touch with them
now now you have a google program now
you have a tic-tac program and now you
have an airbnb program really yeah and
that's how that's how facebook found me
is that i have my experience on airbnb
so
it's
that's really you know the way they
found me they booked me through airbnb
so the language that you use to talk
about it at the top is the healing with
horses but then tell me the benefits i'm
going to get out of it you're going to
learn how to be a better leader for
yourself and for your team you're going
to learn how to improve your
communication skills you're going to
learn boom boom boom boom like all
through the power of horses and the
personality stuff doesn't matter like it
it matters to your process
but it's not a selling prop
to get people to come in i'm not coming
in because i need to know if i'm a dante
or i'm a tracer or whatever right and it
also puts you into a world of
myers-briggs and all the other companies
that now we have to like why is yours
better than myers-briggs we already paid
for myers-briggs why do i care about the
four horse
you know uh uh ideas like that you you
still do it because it's important
because
people will heal differently but it's
not in the not in the presentation
because i don't care about the how
i care about what i'm going to get out
of it of course and what i get out of it
is i'm going to be a better leader i'm
going to be more self-aware i'm going to
heal my wounds i'm going to
be a better communicator i'm going to
like whatever the things are that you
actually will help people with
that's the pitch
okay keem with horses
it's a three-day in in-person experience
or three-hour online experience or
whatever it is where you will learn how
to boom boom boom boom boom all through
the power of amazing horses that's [ __ ]
and now you should feel like what are
those point forms of what are the things
you actually get be a better leader
improve your communication skills heal
from you
what it does not what it is
like what do i get how do i how am i a
better human
yeah how am i a better human as a result
of this like if i'm going to if i'm
going to you know if i'm going to a
doctor i'm going to have a surgery what
do i care care about not having
cancer yeah i don't care what kind of
scalpel he's using exactly but that's
what you're talking about like so here's
the anesthesia we're going to use and
here's a scalpel we're going to use and
was like like who cares all i care about
is a cancer guard by the end of this
thing right
that's what they care about so but it's
still important to have the right scalp
on right anesthesia and right so like
you still follow the process that's just
not the market that's not great
marketing
telling me that
the dante or chase or whatever
because it's the process that people
don't care about right right well i'm a
creator i you know i'm a i'm a generator
i'm i'm definitely not a marketer but
well but this is it this this is that
and it's just simple tweaks like that
because if you're gonna say if you have
on your website
that okay you'll heal with horses
and you switch it from
figure out what your personality your
horse personality type is and if you're
a dante or whatever else which won't
make sense to people but then if you say
well i'm going to teach you how to be a
better communicator and be a better
leader and be a xyz those little tweaks
make a huge difference for people to say
yes or no to you
right i'm looking at my website now i
haven't been on my website in ages
because i don't change it ever
so but i'll see because i'm not sure
what it actually even says as my
headline for
empower your soul discover your purpose
live your zen life welcome to xenogen
no
deal with horses
where's the horses in there there's no
horses in there at all
there's dirt
i can't see it you gotta bring it lower
you gotta bring it a little i see your
tv there you go yeah okay but okay but
this is the thing that could be anything
right like tony robbins might say that
and put a picture of a horse it doesn't
mean that i'm gonna actually get a horse
experience
got it it's healing with horses
or heal with horses okay
and and it's an exclusive three-day
in-person or three-hour online event
with horses
live
well you will learn how to
bang bang bang bang and if it's a if
it's a
like show me a little video of the horse
online or show me the screenshot of the
zoom people with the with dante there or
whatever
because that could be anything like
people have on if you just think about
personal development websites people
will often have
sunrises and mountains and nature scenes
and horses and lions and it doesn't mean
i'm gonna go pet a lion right right so
just the fact you have a jumping horse
doesn't mean i'm gonna get i don't think
i'm getting a horse experience through
this got it
because all of the wording you use just
sounded personal development
yeah
well that's really
that's pretty much what it is you know
personal development coaching healing
leadership but the biggest thing that
you give is the horses yeah like what's
your aha difference it's the horses oh
my gosh
i guess you know i've i've heard so many
things
different i get so many
50
every time the next person will tell me
don't work don't mention the horses it's
not about the horses it's about you it's
about the healing it's about the
leadership you start talking about
horses people think horseback riding
people think seabiscuit don't don't even
bring the horses up
but what are we selling
leadership and healing but through
horses right
otherwise you're just you're just you're
just a speaker
and then it's like why should i hire you
instead of brene brown instead of tony
robbins instead of whoever else but
you're not probably a little less
expensive
well but
great but you're not just you don't want
to be hired just to be
a speaker at the experience
with the horses that i'm getting
okay
it's like it's it's every time i turn
around it's someone telling me the exact
opposite you know
to do well
pick your mentor and then run like in go
and and and start and start uh yeah you
do want to what are you doing a horse
gallop gallop like pick your mentor and
gallop and go
instead of like coming back to the
starting gate and starting over each
time oh my god i can't believe you just
said that that's like that's what i
that's been the problem that's been my
number one issue is like trying to not
you know either not staying with
something long enough or st or
yeah
who says trust your instincts
you know horses horses horses i'm
looking at some of the comments
it's like yeah i i to your point it is
you know it's it's tough it's a it's a
tough sell and i you know i mean i guess
if i keep saying it stuff it will be but
that's this has been my biggest
stumbling block is to try it but it's
not i don't think it's that tough to
sell i think i think it's um i think if
you didn't have the horses it'd be a
really tough sell
yeah hi i'm jen i'm a personal
development person i'm a speaker i can
help transform your culture and change
your leadership into one out of a sea of
people trying to doing that yeah hi i'm
jen i've got my own personality test
that can help you figure out it's like
you're you're
you're
a giant sea of tons of people like yeah
why should i hire you yeah that's tough
the healing with horses is
is different it's fun it's unique it's
like oh my gosh a breath of fresh air
finally the only thing is make the
connections like well how does being
around the horses what's the experience
i get that's going to help me get better
at leadership and communication and
self-awareness and healing and you know
whatever else you're doing
awesome but but it opens the door to
conversation where they they get on a
call with you and then they ask a
question
hey jen how do i how do we do this right
the horses becomes your you're in to
make it
different it's a reason to have a
conversation
agree
and most of the stuff they're doing is
so boring and corporate and sucks anyway
i trust that's so true
so if you're giving people an experience
that's like wow that was
how many how many people at teams are
really excited about the team building
exercises they're about to go on
right it's like if i hit another team
building exercise i'm going to leave
this team
right well and to hear the feedback you
know that you know after
after someone experiences this that the
feedback is 100
i had i
i don't my once somebody comes and does
a little taste of this you know my
conversion rate is
you want to hear the number
it's over 65
so so now you need to follow up with
everybody that's that
once once they get confident and do one
thing
of almost almost two-thirds that's a
you need to like why are they not coming
back for another thing in three months
no that that's not the problem i need i
because i need more i i need more but i
really need because they do come back
but i need more of them
i don't have enough of those i'm just at
that like you said to your point um i'm
back at the starting gate again because
i keep changing what i feel like my
messaging needs to be
you know and you're right about the
website i do need to make that change um
that's absolutely
i think that's going to be critical
and but healing with horses leadership
and empowerment with horses
is that's it i mean that's really what
it is
and and what it does
you know you got my brain going for sure
i knew you would
because you know i i watch all your
stuff and you you really do have a way
to to really shift the mindset and it's
just that little tiny thing that's going
to happen it's not that much work no
i don't have to re do my entire website
i just need to change the thing and put
healing with horses yeah like we don't
need to go build a thousand-page website
this is not a giant project that's going
to take months to finish no i agree
so the two most important takeaways from
this would be one like the the branding
and positioning of it healing with
horses the horses are front and center
and here are the benefits you're gonna
get which which you could do today you
know just update it easy yeah and then
the second part is just the the
follow-up
in the the
deal structure where we're trying to get
annual deals
and any speaking gigs we're trying to
come on there every year what is that
what is a quarterly like how do you come
in and you have one great experience and
then turn that into four experiences
over the next year absolutely and and
then different departments and referrals
and referrals and follow-ups and then a
hundred percent the question a quick
question then what what would you
think could be like a great entry offer
because i've done like the five day
challenge thing i've done you know i've
played with a million different entry
level things that are free excuse me
free or low cost
what you know what would you say would
be
a good because a lot of i'm still doing
a five-day challenge and i'm not sure a
challenge is the right thing
i mean where would you and that's free
and i'm i do events
once every couple i mean i'm always on
doing a something
but
where would be a good entry level based
on what you are you know you should
think what is the
having like not having experienced it
you got to think if somebody's going
through
and they're spending five days with you
what is the what is the easiest to
digest
aha because a lot of like the deeper
inner work you can't just change in a
shift in a second correct what are the
things that
create
create big ahas in a short amount of
time and that's the thing to get them to
taste like it's the appetizer like it
tastes delicious
but it's not going to fill you up
right what what would that look like do
you think like what i don't know like
you got to think through your experience
of of having helped so many people what
is the appetizer to get people
into it so that they feel like wow this
is delicious i want more how do i write
more
that's you know and that we just keep
playing around and playing around with
that like trying to figure out what the
best appetizer is for it like what's the
best lead what's the best legion
experience you know you honestly may not
even need it
if you do a good job
on the other two things that we talked
about that's fair if you fix your
website in the position and also how you
talk about it like if you if you rewind
this back and and explain how you how
did you introduce this topic to me it
all started with the four personality
types of your horses and daunting and
saint madonna explain it's like none of
that matters yet like once i'm in then
that matters but to explain what you do
that stuff doesn't matter yet
like hey i'm jen i help people heal
through the power of horses and i help
people xyz right communication skills
leadership skills right that's going to
make it a lot more
a writing is going to
make it easier for people to understand
what you do not fully not to like the
details right like i don't understand
how the search is going to cut the thing
out of me but i understand the result of
this thing and now i'm curious to learn
you do what you heal people through
horses this is crazy yeah that's right
response that i get
so it creates a conversation right which
is what we want and then two if you do a
good job with the follow-up if you think
about everybody every speaking thing
that you've done and asked them to come
on and do another one if you think about
every organization you've helped even
people who are your in-person retreat
four years ago right right and they've
all like not all but a bunch of them
moved on to other jobs a bunch of them
are still the same company that they're
at and you just followed up with
everybody and said hey i've i'm doing
this online program now
you'll get business
yep
yep that's that's a no-brainer and um
i've i've started um
you know
re-establishing my linkedin more because
i think going to be going to
corporations going to businesses and
because when you get to go when you get
to businesses you're good to individuals
as well
so
i wouldn't even worry about that yet
like that's that's scale and growth and
where where it all can go but
let's get you making some good corporate
money let's get your center opened up
back to the way that you like it yeah i
mean this huge there's huge
opportunities just doing that and you
already have some momentum and traction
there like selling to america the
consumer is the hardest game of all a
million percent
yes so it doesn't mean that we can't get
there especially if your mission is i
want to change the conversation around
horses and and showcase how much of a
problem this is then ultimately we need
to get to america but to go to america
from the start
is insane like that's what i've been
doing though that's that's exactly what
i've been doing is trying to crack the
crack the big nut first
but but the path to cracking the big nut
is through the more exclusive expensive
stuff you're like tesla started with the
tesla roadster it's a six-figure car
that you bought and then they got to the
slowly making it more and more and more
affordable because what's their goal
they want to change
they want every vehicle to be electric
they want to they want to save the world
from pollution right so
but they started with the high end stop
they started with their niche instead of
making money like you need to start
making money yeah so that you can afford
to do all the things that you want to do
i love it
that's you know that just reinforces
what i what i've been thinking about
that like get you know just
get the get the cash flow get the flow
of money coming in to people that
understand get my get my you know early
adopters and my innovators and how many
how many people have you helped that you
actually have some kind of email address
or phone number for
probably about 6 000 emails oh my god
jen that's what that's that's all you
need to do yeah
fix the website you can do that today
don't stress about the perfect picture
and all that just change the language
around what we talked you could watch us
back we'll save it if you want
uh and then start messaging the six
thousand people
who've been through the program who who
already know how great it is because
they've witnessed it so the the
threshold to
to explain it isn't there because they
already know
and then ask them how they might be able
to bring it inside their corporation
amazing
okay
then you'll be filled up like if you do
a good job on the 6000 you'll be filled
up for the rest of the year
yes
you have six thousand people who've been
through your thing yeah
first they know you who like they may
not be your best friend and like follow
everything you do but no they've
experienced it something right they've
experienced something they know the
power of dealing with horses and so
some of them will take you right if you
just had one percent you had 60 people
take you inside the corporation to line
something up
you're busy for the rest of the year now
we're looking at how do i hire more
people how do i explain
right yep i'm ready for that i'm ready
for that day that's gonna be amazing but
that's the path like don't worry about i
wouldn't even worry about your book
don't worry about the social media stuff
don't worry about somebody here
following you
you fix the website with clear
positioning based on what we talked
about and then you you reach out to the
6 000 people
get on calls with them let them know
that you're trying to get into their
their company because you want to bring
this message of healing with horses to
the world i love it you're right 60
people that would be it i would be so
busy i wouldn't know what to do
it's not the path to like crazy it
doesn't change the world yet right like
6 000 companies that the 60 people like
that doesn't change the world yet and
accomplish your mission but it gives you
the momentum and the cash flow
to be able to then go and build the next
thing yeah yeah that's you're absolutely
right
you're absolutely right
well there that's that's you know
marching orders are in place that's easy
and everything you said is easy and i
can do any of it like that's not a
problem you're doing everything so this
yeah this
what are those things that the horses
wear the blinders
blinkers blinkers and blinders yeah
blinkers are on now jen this is yeah
so much no no no
well and that's and you just you just
said what you know what bellas do that's
what bellas do they're like oh shiny we
i call it shiny penny syndrome
you know they have shiny penny syndrome
okay you get some of these put them on
you know
or like or put them in front of your
desk or something you know it's like
that's your little virtual reminder that
okay i'm being a bella again
we're we're we're stopping our own
progress focus and those things actually
i think those things are actually kind
of not so those are bad i don't like
them
yeah the idea of them is to focus
right but just staying focused and and
getting that like you said you know get
get pic pick your horse
and ride it
you know
yeah and that's just it's like my zone
of genius is
the the metaphors and the stories that i
can create around anything
that's you know yes i need focus thank
you thank you for that people in the
comments are like she's focused yeah
thanks guys
so and it's and it's so obvious when you
have a boulder in your eye right it's
tough to see around but that's really
great advice
i do yes that's your next like that's
your next step if you do a good job with
those 6000 and you fix the messaging and
you just fix how you talk about it yeah
you'll get all the business you need for
the rest of the year
and then we can worry about scaling and
then we can worry about how you open a
center in every state and you know
across the country and how do we save a
million horses next year from being
slaughtered and how you know whatever
like the big
things are
right yeah yeah for sure
okay that's amazing thank you so much
all right
thank you jen yes thank you keep us
posted session i hope i hope everybody
that's watching got a lot out of it as
well so thank you very much amazing
we'll see you soon thank you again take
care bye cheers
really she's part of uh moviemaker has
joined us for a year as part of that we
do uh ig live together as well so
sharlene welcome aboard oh thank you so
much it's my pleasure to meet everybody
to meet you i'm honored and to meet
everyone i am normally at work so i'm so
happy to get this opportunity to speak
with you i love it so
what do you got how can i help
yes well i am an author like at email
prior and probably your associates have
said to you and i've been practicing
natural and listicle for over 23 years
and everybody calls me guru i'm the
assistant vitamin manager at sprouts
everybody's like you should be on tv you
should be on youtube you i mean it's
just crazy like i'm telling them like
i'm almost like pastor joel stina kind
of behind the scenes person until
maybe god just pushed me in front but
for now
i was just telling them that i would
think
um i wanted god put it on my heart to
reach over millions of people well
millions of people to help them with
their health
naturally
and that's why i wrote the first book on
basically a pocket guide of eating for
your health and then i'm working i'm a
third of the way off my second book
of mental health and wellness so the
first one was say yes to take care of
your
to to say yes to pure good food and then
the second one is say yes to taking care
of your mental health and wellness i'm
all about
wellness it was just a gift from god
23 years plus and i have to help the
people so i'm like
like oprah did with dr phil and
everybody else and dr oz and iyanla to
get on their platform
i'll always been following evan for
years let me just reach out and join
this thing and support whatever he's
doing and he loves to help people so
you know i just reached out and just
said just leap of faith and we could you
know see if we could partner together
whatever he wants i was like whatever he
wants but
i'm just uh
here to help the people and you're also
saying yes a lot yes might say yes
yes i say i had to do that positive
affirmation you know i watch you a lot
and have been watching everybody from
the you talk about everybody everybody
in the business from oprah to everybody
that you follow i've been following and
you know ian avanzan
um everybody you did every well lisa
nichols
everybody that's been inspirational
those are the people i've been following
for many many years even before i found
you so
it's just my path of being
just that way just to help people
and i'm like this gift god of natural
health the stats are so bad in the
country one-third obese two-thirds over
their weight and i see people all day
long from a rush to stage four kansas so
it's just crazy so where are you stuck
or what do you need help with
meaning to get the word out there in
terms of the book so
people could use it to better their
health naturally i only use natural
remedies to take care of my health over
25 years
so that
that part that's my gift of just natural
health not following that way because
i'm the assistant vitamin manager at
sprouts and i see people come in there
50 30 prescription
ailments all over the body going on and
in the community that i do live is a
quote-unquote affluent cell temple
area and i see and i tell them all the
time regardless of the money it's just
health is wealth regardless so they're
like i'm i'm here as my guru i'm gonna
always come in here for you and
they're just so honored to meet me and
to like i'm the local little person that
they always say she's the go-to and they
send people to me so i'm like
you know and i was just led to just join
the
thing although i did not know the
timeline of when you did your thing i
work at sprout full time as the
assistant vitamin manager i did not know
the timeline but it led on my heart to
just join
your movement and i said let me just do
it even if i just contribute to 500
because i never get a chance i'm at work
and i just said let me just do it and
then i said you know i would love to
partner with you anyone anyone who's who
loves to help people and to
help other people
do you have for us to use our platform
to help people yeah well first off
listen all the trainings are saved as
well so you can always even if you're
not watching live you can go back and
watch them watch all the reasons yeah
i've been trying to catch up
yeah what's the promotion strategy right
now for the book
i have that's that's the pro that's the
point it's just been locally on it's
been on amazon it's self published on
amazon it's just been there and locally
i was selling the book locally and i've
sold hundreds every i really have
locally just by myself i work full-time
in school full-time and i'm a natural
holistic health um coach outside of this
and consultant outside of this i'm i'm
trying each so i sell
there when i meet one-on-one with
clients outside of this because i tell
you these people have no idea in terms
of eating for their health i didn't
realize how bad it was until i started
consulting with people one-on-one so you
do you want that's my strategy online
uh up
anywhere and about anywhere and my
one-on-one so far a full good amount
several hundreds
locally no promotion yet do you wanna in
terms of social media are you trying to
sell the coaching consulting service as
well
no i'm just
well what do you you're the expert in
this with social media i have no idea
what you suggest
i don't know okay so social media
becomes that becomes your
marketing path but it's more like what's
on your heart what do you want to do do
you want to do you want to just be the
writer do you want to be the writer plus
the coach do you want to be speaking
like do you want to be writer plus coach
i take that writer plus coach because
i've been coaching before i start
charging and i basically charge like 89
i tell you right there 89 an hour and
they're glad i'm just so happy and
elated after the one-on-one meeting so i
know i was like goodness i didn't
realize the market for it they're like
we need more of you i was like i wish i
could multiply i've been hearing that
for years do you have a look yeah people
who bought your first book
um some some is in my phone some okay
some of them the best content that you
can put on social
and you know instagram and youtube
uh will be the one that you actually
enjoy the most which will be helping
people
so
yeah
the easiest way to no i was saying that
i don't want i it wasn't ever my dream
to be on youtube and have a youtube
channel personally i thought i would go
the route of partnering with other
people who have a platform and do it
that way it was just never
my dream
of being on there myself literally doing
that one-on-one i know i know everybody
say i should be but it's not my dream of
making videos like i see you do i
rest on my heart for years to just
partner with people who have a platform
and do it that way like
yeah that that's the way i i laid on my
heart and to be honest with you i have
to say so
never the one to like go and make videos
and vlogs and
and all that
well you also do vlogs that's a specific
style of video and you don't have to do
this either um
the more that you have your own
platform the less you're at the mercy of
other people as well so that's something
you can't sure that you can't um
go and part with other people as well i
love that uh one of the reasons why
kevin hart started to blow up and could
command so much money from the movie
studios was because he built his
platform and he can say hey if i'm in
this movie i'm bringing people along the
watch as well
not just being the top secretary
um
it's smart but it doesn't mean it means
lots of smart things you could do it
doesn't have to be the thing that you do
the trick would be like how do you make
it actually fun right most of the time
like making a video might be boring
might be like you just sit in front of a
camera you may not like doing that but
if you made coaching videos then that
could be
a fun path to go down where you're
actually helping people so i thought
like if you have a list of some of the
people who bought your books
the first book
yeah but yeah i do but i don't know if
they're because it's a one-on-one about
their health their privacy
in terms of that if they would want to
do that just it's just a thought
in terms of their private information
and private stuff that we talk about is
just
private in their coaching up their
health one-on-one so i
yeah i don't see our yeah that part i
don't really know how i would make a
video with them with that part so some
people won't okay
and some people yeah some people would
have no problem with it
like if oh if people will go on jerry
springer and talk about the things oh
god they talk about it
no you're too funny with that
no jesus i caught him her number i don't
exactly
yes i don't watch those things but i've
got glimpse everybody on in the world
i've seen the riot and the
yeah that's uh a lot i'm a christian
driven person but i i don't watch news
but i've seen your spring once or twice
and it's a mess
and share their story there uh some
people will come on and share their
story with you and and
if you saw the clientele that i have you
would probably think that they mostly
wouldn't
based on how their demeanor and how they
are they wouldn't
be that kind of type of crowd like jerry
springer they're very yeah sure yeah i
mean and just the point is there are
some people who will share and there are
some people who will share you don't
need everybody you just need a few
people who will come on and share
and the way to do it especially if you
like the idea of being a coach
then i do
if it's if it's like making a video like
what's this we're doing this is coaching
it's just flipped
so oh my god don't put me on the spot i
know i know i'm listening to you that's
why i'm not saying anything i'm
listening but then it would just be
flipped where you're you're then helping
people with their
whether it's the mindset stuff or the or
the nutrition stuff either one
interesting
but the second book is more about
mindset right
yes the second book is mental health and
wellness because i yeah every one of
them when you do read it you'll see i
don't i want a way i don't know to get
you a copy to yeah just to have a gist
of what i do because everybody i've been
so thankful about i've just heard 100
i'm not even 99 100 positive review
about this book they're like this book
needs to get out there i was like i'm
trying they're like yes you need to get
out there talk to people who have a
platform i said i've already thought
that's one of my
main thing that has been resting on my
heart to do so i'm trying so i said you
know what
better than
you
who have always loved to help people and
just have a good uh you know just a good
aura about you
and i just that's why i signed that even
though i've never been on any of the
training i was like okay i'm never gonna
ask my father's money but i'm just i've
joined all of these things and just like
what he's doing in the world and i'm
sure
everybody's like
the thing that everybody keep coming
back without the coaching or they bought
the book
you just got a gift
you just got that gift of health
health is wealth and you got that
naturally we need more people doing it
that the stats are too bad
here in america you just if you anybody
you
partner you will be all right because we
need more of that especially it's a
pocket guide
my favorite book is a hundred is 91 page
and that's where i got the idea to make
it short under 100 page 100 pages so it
is under 100 pages and yeah i have
gazillion books some of them probably
similar to yours because i follow any
thought leader always years on end it's
just been my path
and and i'm like this lay on my heart to
write this book and i finally got made
my former store manager was the author
of 15 books who know how god lined up
things and got this first one published
and
now we're we're friends for life and
then he knows i'm writing my second one
he has 15 books on
amazon so just
just how god has weaved it and then here
i am with you i mean i just like i said
he just like go ahead and join evan's
thing i just listen i just listen and i
know i don't even i didn't know your
schedule know how i was going to do
anything i just signed what what about
sprout
yeah sprouts they use i
this was one of gonna be my big thing
sprouts used to sell book
straws used to sell books so i said okay
i was gonna get my book into all the
sprouts couple months before uh my book
was published
sprouts are stopped selling books
at all they got rid of books so that was
gonna be my major idea just to speak
with higher up ask my store manager
because we're very close and he he just
love he's just like yes he's just a big
supporter too of
what i'm doing my natural health mission
to help people and he's like yeah so he
would have helped me but it's
unfortunately
they
they totally took
all books out of all sprout stores the
memo came down that they're going to get
rid of all the books so
that was just what it is i said on
another opportunity will open do you
work at a specific store or you work for
the whole company
oh yeah specific store in south tampa
here i work near home okay i'm in south
tampa as the assistant vitamin manager
so here's the thing with any of these
things like you can't accept
just don't accept the way things are
done as the way that it has to be done
so just because they stop selling books
it doesn't mean that they can't sell
your book um
one of the things that i did uh when i
was getting started as a speaker is i
went to
uh i'm in canada so the canadian version
of barnes nobles
like the biggest bookstore in the
country biggest bookstore chain and
i said i want to come in and speak at
your
at your location
and they said but you don't have a book
it's like no i i don't want to i don't
have a book to sell but i'll help sell
your books
i'll bring people into the store
and so
they thought it was a little crazy but
whatever they gave it a shot and
yeah i spoke there
uh
either every week or every two weeks for
like a year and we had the second
largest number of people come out to the
bookstore
um
apart from sting sting was number one
and the musician sting was number one
and we were number two
and oh wow because people kept coming
back and so
sure they don't sell books anymore cool
one if you're already at a specific
store
you have some you have relationships and
you have some leeway and you could
probably make it work as a launch just
at that one store but here's
yeah but i gotta tell you something here
real quick so you have an inside it's a
total
different dynamic real quick in one
sentence uh the management has changed
and it's a total like turnover of
employees and not happy and it's crazy
it's different i'm on the
verge of trying to even decide
how long i'm going to stay and all of
that so it's a little bit
different from when the former manager
was there so different totally so yeah i
mean all of that creates opportunity
it's like take take the lemon and you
make lemonade and then you sell it yeah
you know like all of it so
yeah i believe you're not
the goal you don't pitch them as help me
sell my book
you don't pitch them we're not even
selling a book
the book becomes an
excuse to bring people into the store
who then will buy the products
i told them that that's what i was using
until she stopped um the new management
manager
um
her voice dropped and she said yes
they're
not
put it this way they're not for many
people they're not people persons like
yourself to help and all of that it's
more of
sabotage and jealousy it's been going on
throughout the store it's crazy just
different managers can bring different
things
uh yeah i it's crazy because i'm in a
management class i have a year of doing
a management degree just for my bucket
list not any particular reason i found
my passion 23 year plus a girl but i'm
just saying yeah management 101 of
taking care of your people that's not
what the been feeling in the store
lately so not for
if it was the other manager sure i would
have done that
it's just a different pitch right it
it creates opportunity it's not a
problem it's an opportunity so the pitch
is a supportive team
it doesn't even matter about you the
pictures let's grow the business
and if yeah that's what i told her and
it was
it was and she still she want me to
still bring all my custom i had a store
locally for four years and i had one
online and they've all
converted to sprouts and i she knows she
knows i'm our money maker making the
money but guess what that at the same
time my direct management her their they
want to shut d no thriving
they're not people persons they don't
want to see you succeed so it's not even
a thing they're trying to you get
use you take your your your people and
the money but not to
promote anything if i put it bluntly do
you want to just do that and shut it
down like evan i'm trying on your book
but i still want to use you and your
people and all of that not like a good
partnership to say okay
like i am here like
whatever partnership you want with me
i'm fine enough with fear enough with
whatever i'm a giver or whatever like
that's what i mean no open like that i
believe in two-way street no it's not
that kind of dialogue it's wanna i'll
use evan and his people but nope ever
nope for your book a note for this but
i'm just sorry
yeah awesome then then you find another
store
yeah like the model works
if you're saying hey i don't want to do
content i don't want to do coaching i
don't want to make videos cool that's
one way to win partnerships on your
heart you know what you said
it is cool so it is so this is part of
partnerships right some people will take
advantage of you some people won't
listen to you yes a lot of rejection
cool you just gotta navigate and deal
with it
the model works i will right like the
model works i will so if it's not
destroyed
maybe it's a different sprout location
maybe it's a different health like how
many health food locations are there
or even wellness locations yoga studios
dance studios like anything that deals
with health or wellness for the two
books
that
they could have somebody come in like
you
giving a speech like it may be something
they've never done before
true but it brings value to their
to their community to their customers
true so i'm an introvert like you
everything i did but you're doing it so
i'm following you i am
it was at the ymca
and
i um they didn't have they didn't bring
in speakers it wasn't a thing that they
did
but i said hey i'd love to help your
entrepreneur group and share my story is
it okay
and i came in and presented there and
then i i started i came back to the ymca
and then i went to a local bank
um and then evolved into the bookstore
and although all along the way it's like
stuff they had never they've never seen
this before they've never done this
before
but okay it's the willingness like you
make a list of 200 stores
and
20 of them will say yes
and the other 100 and you know 80
maybe they're bad people maybe they're
just stressed out maybe they just aren't
close-minded maybe they'll support
management cool i mean
we love you i mean let me show you that
it works
and then as it works
then you can like if you can make it
work with one sprouts location forget
about the one that you're in cool
make it work bring people into the store
they start buying other products then
now you now you're going on a sprouts
tour
you're hitting up america going every
spreads location
right and if it's not sprouts and it's a
it's a yoga franchise or it's a yeah
yeah i was thinking that i was waiting
for you to say that because i don't yeah
i would yeah would probably try you know
other people don't place them don't
think that's what i'm watching having to
be sprouts it doesn't have to be sprouts
yeah but there's lots of companies that
are like sprouts so sell health products
or services right dane studios et cetera
um where they would find it cool to have
somebody come in
they're looking for creative ways to
market their business and dealing with
people not showing up they're dealing
with inflation like they're looking at
anything um they're looking to get their
name out right like um can we bring some
media to the event can you
can you
like once anybody says yes then you kick
up
a firestorm you start emailing all the
local media and say hey we're doing
we're doing this act of kindness in our
community here i'm an author i wrote
this book i'm volunteering to go speak
at this yoga studio to spread awareness
about mental health and physical
activity
and out of the 40 reporters you email
four will pick it up and say oh that's
actually pretty cool
it's momentum okay so no it's like it's
what kevin hart did right when he did
his tour back to kevin hart he was torn
as a comedian before anybody knew who he
was or cared about him and any
everywhere he went he just made it he
got their email addresses and built his
list and then the next time he came back
there were double the people there and
the next time he came back there was
like four extra number of people there
and if you want to do partnerships as
your main strategy that becomes a path
you know like hey i'll come in i'll
present i'll do q a i've got a book to
sell too people want to buy it but the
main focus at the beginning is not
sell the book the main point is to help
customers who are helping people yeah
yeah completely helping people with
their health is
is my main
thing totally i totally agree my main
thing is is
yeah forget about that once i help
people with their health
they're always inclined to buy i realize
the book or whatever else that comes
it's just
get that get that to help people but i
know i didn't want to be in front but i
based on all your strategy i'm gonna
have to
push myself out there and
be seen even though i would rather
be like you at first and just kind of
not be seen but i guess you could go in
and if you go in and give a great talk
at the yoga studio then maybe they sell
your book
you know like you're building
relationships
yeah building relationships i gotta be
seen so i gotta put it in my head
i gotta do it i just gotta
go out there and totally put myself out
there to these places even though i
didn't wanted to be behind the scenes
somehow but i got i hear you and i
respect you so i will be trying to get
brave bruh
trying to get braver
or trying to get brave
to do it yeah
i'm going to try you make a if
partnership is the way you want to go
then you make a list of 200 people
who have places that you can go and
speak at
that are related to health and wellness
somehow
that you can you can help their audience
their customers and totally help and
then the goal becomes
you have to refine the the model in the
system but as you start doing these
events whatever four people show up 15
people show up 20 people show up like
it's building the model yeah but then
you can yes to
a national franchise
and then go on a
north america tour
spreading health and wellness to their
audience
oh my god
you think big and i and i like it but
lord i i have to try to
to process it i just yeah give me a
while to process it i was thinking
behind the scenes
and just do my little partnership don't
stress but i know i am trying to process
it sometimes sometimes the big thing
becomes too big and then it's scary and
we don't do anything so
don't stress that doesn't have to that
doesn't have to be the thing but
yeah you can work towards it and we take
one baby step at a time because you know
the yes totally i believe in that baby
ten years ago wouldn't have thought that
you'd be writing books and now here you
are with the second one coming out
i know i know totally i'm like
yeah that part i was like look at that
totally yeah i agree i totally make a
list of 200 stores
local businesses all right that do
health and wellness in your area that
you can go in
and do some kind of presentation to
that will help their audience and see
how all right so i will take i will take
that as my thing for you but please
consider me in terms of partnership with
me i've been always wanting to do one
with you so if
just let me know how you'd want to
proceed and go about that i mean you
never know
it's not
right like as you start doing these
things
the model becomes a lot more clear so
then you can go to people
and
be able to have something tangible to be
able to give them
as a model
okay
all right i will take that i appreciate
you and appreciate your time for
everybody watching what's the name of
the book again
tell us both of them
say yes to pure good food
is the first one and the second one of
course and the one is coming out yes
that's on amazon yes and the second one
is going to be say yes to taking care of
your mental health and wellness i'm a
third of the way and when does that come
from so
i my goal is december okay listen
i'm trying to do this
full time school and work wise
how do you say your last name
everybody calls me that from high school
so i'm gonna take it but it's actually
we no but it's true everybody say why w
e i s e go check her out shirleen thank
you for the love thank you for the smile
thank you for your first this yeah we
made it happen yes i know i would jesus
thank you so much thanks everybody and
thank you so much evan i really
appreciate it
i totally i'm honored to meet you
soon
bye
if you want to see me coach another
entrepreneur check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there that's what they need the most
because everybody in their life is
judging them and telling them what they
should do and they feel like a piece of
garbage
that's what they're telling themselves
you don't have to be the expert on all
those things yet you can just talk about
what you're doing and what you've seen
with those things